hi you georgie
chucky that has perfect my chucky
impression yeah
tim curry you want some candy
oh dude you're killing it today doing it
one more one more you got it in you i
know you do i come in your nightmares
yes this is a classic quote from chucky
love robert england's chucky i was
actually going for a pirate but guys we
reached into the chucky finale thanks so
much for being here please go ahead and
slash that like button and also
subscribe click the notification bell
for whatever other crap we cover on this
channel hey full length watch long as we
sync up with us to watch chucky are over
at our patreon page cover bunch of crap
over there as well at the same tier you
get the options you've probably heard me
mention before and also eric over at
nerd chronic thanks so much for adding
these down for us buddy there's a longer
episode
all right
is your dad home
this way
homeboy has fully correct yep
hint of guilt over what he did he's got
that soft killer voice now and ask if he
has chucky
humor me okay
you're the two most socially weird
individuals i've ever seen in my life
this is like a suss off
[Laughter]
tell him to call me
and junior if you see the doll
stay away from him
[Music]
if he can reach around the bathtub
[Laughter]
i hate guns they're like
my achilles heel along with the axes big
industrial-sized
fans
huh
you hungry
oh wow
cool
it was all leading to this
maybe it has something to do with that
doll you got at the bus station
i left it in the kitchen
i speak of the devils don't ever leave
any chucky doll anywhere
nice
kyle
wow
yeah
cool go kyle don't worry
i have a plan
run them over
bulldozer
oh
what is this plan
does not feel comfortable he feels quite
sinister
where did nico go
where
is she
don't be scared it's just a little you
won't see him oh
wow oh
good sell
this will be the last time babe
i promise
you can't kill me jackie
you need me think about
it thinking is for losers
again
whoa who ears my sweet face
help her out
yeah
help me up [ __ ] come to mama come to
mama
good guy
oh girl
looking good doll
you're not looking so bad yourself sweet
face
oh i twisted this all in
kill them all
any questions
is there an age limit
what good question
no babies we're not savages
could you define
baby
brad durf must have gotten like 18
paychecks right yeah he gets a paycheck
per doll
[Music]
oh chuck he's just in love with himself
chucky chucky
chucky
a real man would know how to treat a
lady
like junior but i don't see no lady
wow
oh here comes nika
say character nico what no
everybody
killer
no no no no
i'm sorry
you know what that does to me
i do for you i don't want to do it who
is it you're afraid of losing tiff
junior
do it
it's not like she's my dad
come on man i'm not ready for this it's
weird
i'm ready to kill strangers
who's she she's your goddamn trophy now
do her or i'll do the three of you
wow
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
junior who are you gonna trust to get
you out of this [ __ ] town me
oh he's getting off on this
you just saved your whole relationship
i'm done with your petty [ __ ] and your
massive ego and your tiny [ __ ] dick
tell me something
how those cops found you that night in
chicago oh
oh
this is all building up to dang
damn
that's a reveal yeah i have some
information
on the lakeshore strangler
via khan deals
see you in hell
my job
what's that
isn't it cute
my darling glenda gave it to me
oh exquisite taste are they coming back
a little something to welcome auntie oh
yeah
oh wow
that's poor devin
she's being made privy to all the worst
[ __ ] in the world right now
this is going to be for a great podcast
cool
i love it
kill the twink
come on man that's mean
for that kind of language
i'm keeping this head i need a new one
to put in my safe
where the [ __ ] are you i'm
everywhere
uh-oh oh no no
no
wow
oh what the [ __ ] is devin okay and
legacy character andy
and
also legacy character yeah it says yes
dude but mostly andy intended
hey we did it
you and i we didn't
[Laughter]
check your
alerts
oh no
oh
i don't know
oh
no
oh
we haven't seen a body yet i'm not gonna
panic
yeah oh god
only cry a little bit
also his fatalities
where reported go
i know it's easier to run
after everything yeah thank god
oh [ __ ] yeah
that's a
ghost it's a dream
hey
chucky
no
don't get stabbed in the butt
oh man
is he dead
oh my god oh
no
my dude
you're such a good guy
oh
[Laughter]
that is so sick gross
oh
jesus
what a place to get stabbed
oh yeah
this is still carrying the popcorn
oh
who's still sitting there
should i should i wait for the crowd to
disperse
oh
oh ouch
come with us and it'll be better than it
ever was before
you were me not like that
now just [ __ ] your way through this
it's fun
i mean your real project is a little
girl man
he's coming go
here i am [ __ ]
come and get me
they'll think of hackensack as ground
zero for the army of me
not if i kill you first
chucky's a terrorist
hey man
i'm done with murder sprees i want to
get more
how cost-effective a little dog possibly
be so strong doesn't
make any sense
killer now junior
killer or i will
nice
wow
[Music]
dig deep
oh
i don't need that [ __ ]
all i need are my bare hands
when i killed your dad you were thrilled
i knew he'd never be able to hurt me
again and this is how you thank me
then i was pissed i accepted you
your father never would have if you only
got the chance to meet devin
oh
hey man you've been having all kinds of
fluid experiences lately
total recall
nice
i was seven
watch your [ __ ] mouth that's right my
boyfriend you're talking to him
official
definitely be my boyfriend
oh
i guess maybe just kyle
she was like
at the door
i don't know they were in the basement
with the bomb
[Laughter]
now he's got to do is make sure none of
them wake up in the middle of the drive
no yeah i don't think we've had the
pleasure i'm tiffany the doll not the
person
it's complicated
[Laughter]
just drive
you know what's good for you
wow if we were gonna see her
i really like you
after all we've been through
sometimes the girls just gotta advocate
for herself
what'd you
do i fixed it what did you do
[Music]
what the [ __ ] what
no
oh
[Music]
oh that is so mean that poor knee
already gosh jesus
has she been through enough
junior wasn't born with evil in his
heart chucky put it there like you tried
to do with me
you guys stopped it
thanks for saving my life
oh
you can never tell anyone what really
happened
not even miss fairchild you have at
least one security camera yeah
the three of us are enough
even though believing in one another is
not easy standing together does not come
naturally that's how we fight back
that's how we win
no
hello
i didn't see you there
i'm tired
and i hope you enjoyed my new show let's
review
shall we
i scored one in mexico
and let us not forget
the good old-fashioned stabbings
wow debbie james gonna have a much
easier season yeah
drop this in
but what about andy and nika
and that truck full of chuckies
what kind of ending do they get
a word from our sponsors
[Music]
[Laughter]
boy oh boy
just to drive home we would like a
season two pleats
that was uh
it was a finale that was that was all
no holds barred man all the stops pulled
out
there's some stuff still left before
awesome
awesome stuff you know what just hit me
right now in this very moment
i'm so late to realizing this so late
this is something i'm sure all of you
noticed
and i it's just now clicking with me
that this is the first thing in the
chucky franchise to only be called
chucky yeah
and i'm pretty late and it's cool
because it's like a
definitive
deconstruction
same time it's not like a deconstruction
of like
uh you know because a lot of times you
say the word deconstruction it's like
this is how you've perceived it now
we're gonna break it down yeah to show
you what really is going underneath
that's usually what deconstruction is
applied for so but it's it's honoring
chuckie and it is the most chucky out of
any chucky it is yeah it's
quintessential in that way it is his
show and i
i think it's so excellent it's the the
funny part about this series is i think
even if you i think you need some
familiarity with the franchise i don't
think you need to know everything like
like have it all memorized or really
have it ingrained in your noggin in
order to keep up with this show
um
but you need to have some familiarity or
else you just won't give a [ __ ] about
some stuff i think like even if you've
never seen like if you're not familiar
with andy at all i feel like none of
that will
matter to you really it'll just be a
fact because he's not the most fleshed
out character nor is he the best
performer
like as an adult to be totally upfront
he's not yeah some of his my favorite
moments of his word in this episode
yeah i mean of his yes
i don't think he has my favorite moments
but no his they're my favorite yeah yes
yeah exactly um and i thought for a
finale they they did a great job i i had
a thought
at the halfway point
of i wonder how i'm gonna end up feeling
about this because
it i love how this show
brought you new characters to take on
this journey and then i feel like
a lot of it has become about
you know tiffany
nica not so much in like all about nika
but
it was it was feeling less like jake and
devin and lexi's show to me yeah yeah as
in the lat and last few episodes but the
last half brought it home
for them to make this a complete circle
for a season one finale
which left me
very very pleased
yeah all around like jake's little
character arc here of really being able
to come into his own stand up become
strong accept his gayness that's right
come out of the closet to chucky
yes that's my boyfriend i'm gay yeah
you'll never take him from me we're
gonna do stuff to each other lately gay
stuff
and it's perfectly natural perfectly
natural
uh really really strong in some ways
cathartic i i thought it was interesting
to
have the finale of this
really play against the backdrop of
frankenstein oh yeah because
frankenstein is
is probably my favorite of the universal
monsters
because he he's not really especially
like in frankenstein and bride of
frankenstein he's not a real
monster like he's
they really especially bride of
frankenstein really shows you he's just
wildly misunderstood and he longs for a
connection
and i think that's what this show really
brought for chucky
was he does
as much as of a sociopathic narcissistic
manipulator like he is evil he's a
serial killer who had a terroristic plan
uh
he there is this part of him that you
see throughout this show
that does kind of want
connection yeah yeah to be able to share
this with somebody yeah yeah to paint it
and he has that whole like speech where
he's being choked we're like i know he's
trying to manipulate jake but i feel
like there's parts of this that come
through from truth or even when it's
with lexi and junior yeah it feels
genuine when he was like i was your
friend i had your back i was trying to
get your life in order for you yeah yeah
so not that this show necessarily draws
sympathy for chucky but i wonder for
mancini
uh for a guy who has you know had this
character for
it's like decades at this point decades
yeah
and and
has evolved the the work looks like it
started off great and it started going
low and then he started going back up
and then you got this show which is the
best critically received eddie chucky
thing ever
yeah absolutely um
you know it's it just started making me
think from a creator angle like he must
have this
uh a part of him that really understands
chucky in a way that we're
i don't know if the right word is
sympathetic but or empathetic but
there's got to be like a level you have
to have a level of understanding of the
the deeper layer to
um charles lee ray yeah
the kernel of humanity that this was all
growing out of yeah it's like even if he
is a complete murderous yeah like you
said narcissistic sociopathic psychopath
at the same time and then i think the
the earlier flashbacks especially
bolster that when you see him like as a
child and there is a kind of almost
michael myersy thing of like is this
kid's just off
but yeah there is a certain attention to
like chucky's motivation and
characterization is pretty consistent
and i feel like between don mancini and
brad derif they probably have just like
this iron-clad bible of how chucky stuff
works uh but yeah it's that drives it
all home because that
gets you pat like the gimmick of the
chucky doll and everything and the you
know serial killer inhabiting that is
already good enough but to keep the
longevity going and to keep your cannon
because you know as the movies got more
broad and more comedic you know you are
doing things that all that hearken
directly to like you know bride of
frankenstein pride and chucky things
like that him having like his own little
twisted family and yeah i think that's
part of the longevity is that there's
always those core nuts and bolts
elements of his serial killer side but
there's also this demented yeah
human underneath it all right and that
really brings everything together and
that really i think drives the
manipulation he's able to bring to all
these different characters that's what i
love about what he's done with this
franchise in particular because
it seemed like the progression of the
chucky franchise would be just go more
ridiculous yeah you know go more insane
and then you do this show
where while you keep like the voodoo
aspect and the multiple chuckies you
know all these things while you but you
have these supernatural elements that
you are
enhancing
it never got too big yeah which was the
concern with the good guy doll thing but
even as i was progressing in this
episode alone
i was impressed with how it still felt
there's gotta be another word other than
grounded grounded yeah the name contains
probably the better word for it more
more contained
and uh because they didn't go all out
with like oh he's you know mass
occurring there's a million no
i thought that was a really smart choice
and that goes back to understanding the
core of how much to feature and how to
use chucky as yeah a part of you sees
that line up at the end of the previous
episode and goes oh damn it's going
gonna be havoc there's gonna be a
million of them out and around but it's
almost scarier to imagine no these are
all in a truck and they're going to
children's hospitals yeah you know and
that lets it just germinate in your mind
and that's so much more cruel and so
much more horrific without having to go
full ganzo just like there's a chucky
everywhere yeah so you can still get
that suspense throughout the episode of
when and where chucky's gonna show up
and even at the beginning i was like the
whole thing as as kind of kooky as the
scene between junior and andy is when
they're in the house together
i was smart to like still tease like
when are we gonna see him where did he
go
and they always keep that aspect uh
ingrained throughout you know at least
this series
junior just had a slingshot man yeah he
really did
he got really high off that first kill
i've not
i i wonder
that i'm really in conflict about it
because i thought it worked for the
immediacy of this episode yeah uh it did
when i look i wonder when i when the day
comes when i re-watch this season
perhaps in preparation for season two
well when i rewatch this
if
the arc of junior into this will still
feel natural yeah at least because it is
such like
there is no room
only until the very ending moment
when he is talking with lexi yeah where
you start to see he's breaking a little
bit but it after he killed his dad it it
is like that snap it is that crack so
like i'm not conclusive here on my
feelings on it it was just a little bit
like i was expecting a little bit more
layers
to to follow up the last episode after
killing your own father who because he
is as much as he was mad at his father
he also clearly loved his dad and wanted
actual connection and approval watching
what jake talks about later in the
episode about like the chance to get
past all this and to maybe become
friends yeah yeah they they definitely
i felt like a lot of episodes i made it
clearly he really loved his dad yeah and
uh not one
part of this episode
seemed to acknowledge the guilt of that
yeah and it's funny because last night
you said like oh this 90 minute finale
and then we sat down to watch and i'm
like okay it's 90 minutes with
commercials
which is really like an hour and i feel
like yeah if you had a couple extra
scenes
because it is such a huge turn with
junior and yeah one of the kids finally
commits to killing and then yeah it's
like i think they do
for my experience watching this episode
i appreciated that throughout they do
give you moments and and reaction shots
from junior at least watching kind of
his progression through this but i think
yeah with a few more scenes they could
have dealt with the struggle of that
more to then motivate the turn with lexi
and the and the sort of reclamation of
his character just before the moment of
death i don't know i've never been
around a killer before me too so i i
don't know
the the thing is junior didn't have the
traits
of like the guy that got here like this
guy who could be a serial killer but
that's the thing
so the yeah yeah that's the thing and
also if you do something that horrific
on a very basic psychological level the
first thing that would happen is you
would go into shock so you would just
immediately like that's a very hard
thing for a teenager to
especially one who is obviously not full
on you know detached sociopathic
uh
but for him to
there's a part of it that i have the the
exact opposite of painting as to why it
would work
because if you do something that
horrific a teenager like that can't deal
with what they just did so they would
just completely close off any and all
feelings yeah towards what they did and
just block it all
and just
go with the detachment and settle them
here now i'm just yeah i just got to
keep going now yeah yeah so i could
totally see the opposite choice working
and just i guess this is more about the
uh
when i watch the back of the execution
of it flows but i mean yeah that was the
most
that part of it felt a little campy yeah
but it was work though that was the
thing it was working like because
because he had two episodes two tones
here that you dealt with but the first
half was you know tiffany nica devin the
dolls which is like almost a rob
zombie-esque version of the chucky world
right like everyone's just really loud
and angry and reactive and uh easily
provoked
uh
each other yeah and it's just they
bicker and fight and
kill you it makes sense they put a rob
zombie song underwear
yeah yeah so you have that scene
and a lot of that tone is very different
towards the not that they feel at odds
with each other but once you get past
that scene and then it's the next day it
goes back to being more of the human
emotional [ __ ] that chuck that this show
has done so well yeah uh so for that
purpose i i thought it it worked in
effect and like yeah there are moments
where he's like oh i can't kill her i
don't know or you know yeah so they had
they had those choices yeah uh i think
the arc they've done with lexi is
incredible yeah
yeah kudos to that actress she's [ __ ]
great because
i i he hated her
i like hated her and
then i
really cared about her like when it came
to that moment with junior and her
i really felt like this could go with
junior could kill her absolutely yeah i
loved being in that place of like he
could he he could kill her he could at
least try i don't know if he's gonna you
know i i don't know if he is gonna you
know go full chucky and be like don't
try to manipulate me right now you you
know he could have easily fired back
with all the times and things about her
that aggravated him and i loved the way
they both played that scene and when she
was like i was a total [ __ ] i have no
excuse and you always forgave me like
like watching these characters strip
down to the things they haven't been
able to say that are buried under all
this different baggage from just being
teenagers and having trouble at home
like that stuff really resonated uh
quite nicely i thought and i thought
it's clever too for how they end this
off that would you could see how how
everyone died
no one's got a good glimpse of the doll
that did it yeah
yeah it's like it looks like accidents
or it's covered in chaos you watched
freaking eight episodes and you're like
oh damn it it would be no one would
believe them that a doll did this yeah
no matter how many more people come
around to believing that it's the doll
because they encounter it
it's a they're just the cult of chucky
yeah
man like that's the thing is there's so
many wonderful little layers across this
that function on so many levels because
you have all your camp and your gore and
your you know mean spirits but then you
also have a really conscientious like
i'm really i've been amazed how they're
able to slide back and forth between
levels of camp things that are actually
kind of gross and disturbing things that
are really touching things that are
funny things that are you know they give
you both flavors of the slasher where
sometimes it's that twisted like ah you
know we're along for the ride and
sometimes it's the visceral oh god
please no yeah they did they brought
that a lot i thought for this one the
horrific
feelings that come with
with this type of murder yeah
and i think that helped make this
episode especially as the season finale
feel like a truly big and momentous
episode and especially like i as much as
it is kind of like a horror movie
gimmick
at this point in time you know the
cutting back and forth between
frankenstein and the use of you know the
audio and visual motifs and moments that
they spliced into everything gave it you
know a really fun uh both energy
and also a sort of nice homage to
certain frankenstein themes that come to
play in these stories and then on top of
that you have you know the fact that
chucky in his own way is you know in the
pantheon of these timeless monsters now
i mean maybe not to the same
little respectability level as a
frankenstein but you know it felt
appropriate to me especially in a series
that has had so many things that sort of
nod to frankenstein i mean this is the
best chucky anything i've ever seen
absolutely 100 i think it's it's the
best out of all of them all man this
seems like the tech like right now where
i'm sitting this is like the textbook
way you take an existing thing and
expand upon it while maintaining
everything you loved about that all the
all the great stuff about the movies
and then fleshed out with just good
storytelling and character work i mean
it was really cool to get to this point
where you start off with a doll came
into the possession of one boy one guy
and then you watch as a
this insidious
being just
slowly tears this town down
yeah and again that's clever it's really
clever watched over the course of eight
episodes and it felt natural and never
rush
or too much like it really took its time
and to get to this point we had to
massacre the theater i was like damn
this is i like it one part of me like
this has been disgusting because that
worry he's stabbing them just grosses me
the [ __ ] yeah absolutely it's really
disgusting
uh at the same time though i'm like this
is really clever because
he you've been watching this plan just
sort of unfold of him just trying to
manipulate one kid and then that speech
that chucky's giving to jake
uh okay damn that was remember yeah
although just be it all remember is the
number i'm like damn ain't that a fact
that yeah that's the thing is so many
things now especially in these lanes of
hor i'm curious to see how scream you
know reinvents itself now because so
many things do that commentary and even
the last halloween movie was like three
murders in 1978 like there's something
about
it's not necessarily commenting on like
chucky itself but that felt like a very
sharp meta moment of like
yeah in terms of massacres and in terms
of human violence and and the small
towns that like yep they become famous
for horrific grizzly events and for the
person who committed them yeah and even
these movies are pretty much like that
because we don't remember all the
different victims as well as we remember
the iconic villain and all that stuff
and then it caps off with chucky doing
the kill count absolutely yeah which is
like i i have to i like that's got to be
a direct
a direct nod almost i mean there's like
kill counts and i'm sure i'm sure james
a janiece is friends who someone who
involved with chucky yeah yeah um
actually i don't know if that means been
covering this but uh
beyond that it's like the way the kill
count is done but the kill count also
being like beyond the meta of the fact
that
you know more than that debbie james
obviously the most popular one to do it
but there's other people have done kill
counts before
and then of course how he talks about
numbers yeah
it works on multiple layers so i really
appreciated like doing that count
yeah because i'm like i don't know the
names of most of these people who died
yeah the thing and i mean
and for as many endings as this episode
has like it felt like they really threw
in everything like they left nothing no
fun thing they could do like it didn't
feel overly indulgent and yet it also
didn't feel i mean there's the obvious
the setup for the next season but it
really feels like they just threw in as
much as they could and had a blast doing
it you know yeah there's a lot open for
what they could do with the sequel
obviously andy tiffany the dollar
tiffany
um
uh
lexi
likes his parents dying but lexi's
sister
yeah total psychopath a little girl you
could tell when you when you see how
what happens with these characters when
they age off of their experiences with
chuckie i'm it's you like man i wonder
like 10 years from now when the chucky
franchise is still going what to do with
that character yeah totally uh nika
who
who does look like she has the eyebrows
she has the eyes of red door yeah she's
a daughter right yeah
um makes sense why she does such a good
job of doing chucky and and why they
like they really are able to do twisted
horrific stuff with her and i get the
sense that you could only you could do
it if you don't have this but by now the
chucky there's got to be a chucky family
oh yeah i'm sure she can get on board
with the morbidity just the no holds
barred wacky horrific qualities and i
love the way she plays both characters i
mean she's excellent slipping in and out
of both she's even good at pretending to
be chucky and she's even good at chuckie
pretending to be nico yeah absolutely
and even i mean as much as as much as
the adr and the flashbacks can be sort
of distracting i mean i thought it was
really cool the way they just let her be
charles lee ray because for the most
part i mean you can tell there's some
prosthesis and stuff but
like that seems like a very rare and
cool opportunity that they took to let
her do that
wow okay
that's right you did tell me that she
also plays charles lee ray yeah cause
that blew my mind at first at first i
was like oh they must have just cast
some young actor who kind of looks like
everybody when i was watching it today i
was like it's crazy how that guy does
look like charleston yeah how he does
and it's easy to forget yeah
i completely even though i knew that you
told me that i completely forgot about
that
and it's like it's such a weird little
thing to have happen but it's like it's
it's it feels very well suited to the
kind of strangeness this show is great
at or just chucky things when they're
doing it right excel at yeah and i
appreciate it too how they did a good
job on discerning the personalities of
the multiple chuckies there's like a few
heads that were very
uh
you know they they were full flushed and
then
the rest were this like discount chucky
yeah yeah you got a couple of hero
chuckies and the rest are just kind of
like
that
yeah that was their version like they
felt like
not fully developed clones in a way yeah
like they're diluting the more he puts
his soul into yeah yeah whereas the
other ones felt uh like just
like pure chucky yeah
so yeah i mean and then we had uh
kyle yeah she's uh supposedly dead at
the moment i mean one of them had to
have died i don't know ridiculous that
all three of them would survive that big
blow up at that house half of me is
expecting i mean yeah and i'm like okay
i'll give devin the editing benefit of
the doubt andy
i'll give him okay i'll give them the
the he's andy and so he has to survive i
guess benefit of the doubt kyle seems
like she would be dead she opened the
booby trap yeah she stepped right into
it yeah
but part of it yeah yeah yeah yeah
but i feel like andy was i mean he's in
the basement where the bum oh that
literally was so you know like that is a
bit of a mumbo jumbo
oh but it seems like kyle might be
especially dead
we got tiffany and then they talked
about glenda a couple of times
yeah glenn glenda that's the play on uh
the edward right leonard glenda yeah uh
yeah i've talked about glenna glenda a
couple times in this show
but we haven't seen her they them them
them
they're gonna get my
gotta get my terminology right yeah
you're right chuck you'll
i accept my gender fluid child but
you're a queer
that's so weird so interesting all right
guys well thanks so much for being here
this was a blast of a show um would you
go ahead subscribe click that bell hit
that like button and hey let's do a p
andrew hayes i want to shout out andrew
hayes
because
if i got a doll for christmas
i i would hope that it would be an
andrew hayes doll
i'm sorry buddy but do i need to say
more
you you you know you'd make a good you
would make a good doll and you would
have the perfect voice short stocky come
on do the andrew hey boys and andrew
hayes i'm here i'm your friend to the
end
yeah exactly just
pushing his little belly
and then i want to pick locks and he's
also like a tough little guy too he
could be tough so he could you know if
he was the doll that could come to life
and i wanted him to help me
take out some people and he didn't like
him
he'd be lovable cute charming i'd cuddle
him and at the same time he could be my
massive real killer
adorable but then when he's like running
at you with a knife it's like the
scariest thing you could imagine that's
what i mean andrew you be the perfect
christmas present to unwrap oh yeah
imagine him in that box behind the
plastic just looking at you you guys
don't get it
there is no one else at our patreon
so thank you for being you andrew and
merry christmas merry christmas
[Music]